that's me
red ever since I was a kid I never
really fit him no one understands me
hey red how are you oh I'm horrible mr.
riah
yes seems to be a recurring issue Bonnie
the anger might be contagious he started
it
unbelievable not working not working oh
where are we going yeah we practice this
a hundred times
give it to me ah we're gonna come in
again these pigs serious and weird am i
right look I don't trust them I think
they're up to something all pinyin is
not me you said what I think it is you
think those are fragile right not yours
you all make it I will get you a welcome
and you're not asking basic questions
doesn't anyone see what's going on here
the whole world is in danger and it's up
to us to stop the Pixar stealing I set
sail for piggy island you tried to tell
us but we didn't listen what do we do
now that is where they went and so that
is where we're going we're gonna get
those eggs back come on we're birds
we're descended from dinosaurs we're not
supposed to be nice oh yeah
point made and Gaia did wow about that
she can shoot fireballs out of her butt
calling the piggy airport
are you coming back ah
did we win remember the goal is the
castle get to the castle
just that you
you